arkansas passed a bill banning the
genital mutilation of children and i
believe that well the bill was
passed by the arkansas senate hasn't
been signed by the governor yet i
believe
but the daily wire reports the arkansas
said it passed the
arkansas save adolescence from
experimentation act or safe act on
monday
now it heads to republican governor asa
hutchinson's desk for him to sign into
law
the state government has a compelling
interest in protecting the health and
safety of its citizens especially
vulnerable children house bill 1570 says
let's go to what the bill bans here's
the list
the bill bans a physician or other
healthcare professional from providing
gender transition procedures to any
individual under 18 years of
age okay a physician
or other healthcare professional from
referring any individual under 18 years
of age to any healthcare professional
for gender transition procedures
it also bans public funds from being
directly or indirectly used granted paid
or distributed to any entity
organization or individual
that provides gender transition
procedures to any individual under 18
years of age
there's a little more to it than that
but that's that's the basic thing there
it is specifically about protecting kids
under 18
miners from
having these things done to them that
cannot be fully reversed
and that they cannot consent to
because they're minors and supposedly
we all agree in in most other contexts
that minors cannot consent
they don't have the full capacity
consent because they don't
their brains are not fully developed yet
their brains will not be fully developed
especially the parts of their brain
that are involved in discernment
involved in long-term thinking and
planning
those parts of their brain won't be
fully developed until 25 so they're far
away from that
which which means it it's incoherent to
say
oh well we want to do this procedure
on this 16 year old because they this is
what they want
and it's best for them that's incoherent
they don't really know what they want
and they have no idea what's best for
them
they can't choose it
in effect if you are
doing a a procedure you know to use the
euphemistic phrase if you're doing a
procedure if you are mutilating the
genitals of a 16 year old
you are doing it against their will
period
because they cannot choose it
it's the same thing we would say if
there was a six if there was a
uh you know a forty-year-old man
having sex with a sixteen-year-old child
we would say that was against that
child's will
even if they verbally consent it it's
against their will because they ca
they cannot actually consent they cannot
psychologically consent to this
that's really the way to phrase this
this this bans
doctors from performing these procedures
on people against their will
and if they're doing it to kids against
their will
now msnbc and the rest of the media
responded to this about the way you'd
expect
but i thought this segment was it almost
managed to stand out for how incredibly
dishonest and misleading it was let's
let's listen arkansas governor asa
hutchison
has already signed a law banning women
and girls from competing on sports teams
consistent with their gender identity
now the state legislature has sent
another
anti-trans bill to his desk one that
would ban minors from receiving gender
affirming health care
unfortunately arkansas is not an outlier
according to the aclu's latest account
legislators in more than half the states
have introduced or
passed some type of anti-trans
legislation what is motivating this
other than hate yes jonathan we are
seeing a
terrible wave of anti-transgender bills
across the country
and you know this is nothing new for the
lgbtq community over the years we have
seen
all different types and ways of trying
to exclude
lgbtq people from daily life but these
attacks are particularly
egregious we're seeing attacks on young
people on their ability to participate
in school in school sports
and we're seeing attacks on the ability
to access life-saving gender affirming
health care
and so the nastiness and the in the
message from all of these is we do not
want you
here we do not want trans youth in our
schools we do not include you and we
we wish to keep you out of our daily
life
so terrible aclu
trans justice campaign strategist i
cannot think of a more useless
collection
of words is there a more useless title
than that
the whole thing is is what they're
talking about again what they're
defending here
is the genital mutilation of children
and and the um
the chemical castration of children
because those are kinds of drugs that
they're using
on these kids chemically castrating them
these are bills that ban the chemical
castration of children and what you have
there are
you know leftists on a major media
outlet
openly defending it
defending it here's the thing defending
it not as
uh they're they're not approaching this
as though they're defending a very
controversial
stance okay uh they're defending it like
this is obvious
how could anyone how could anyone be
against chemically castrating a 14 year
old boy
this is unbelievable this is absurd
the only reason that you could be
against it is hate
well yeah you're right actually you're
right about that i am against it for
hate
i hate the idea of doing that to a kid
i do i personally i
really hate the idea of chemically
castrating kids
of uh of generally mutilating them i
hate that idea
so you're right
but notice that the euphemism again now
it's um
[Music]
and it keeps it keeps changing once upon
a time we used to call this
a sex change surgery and even that
so it's it's it's euphemism on top of
euphemism on top of euphemism
even the term sex change surgery
was ridiculous because you you cannot
actually do that
okay you you you mutilate a man's penis
you have not
changed his sex at all you haven't even
come close to doing it
you you can't do it it'll never happen
but that at least there you had the word
change
and surgery okay so that it was the sex
part sex change that's where the
the euphemism and that's how it became
misleading but at least you had
change and surgery so you knew that okay
this is surgery it's something
a little more serious surgery is a
serious thing and we're changing
something
we're making a change
but the left can't that even that little
bit of honesty
they cannot allow and so he went from
uh sex change surgery to gender
reassignment
surgery which now now we're going way
into the weeds of delusion here
growing sex now it's gender doesn't make
any sense because they say that gender
okay the gender has nothing to do with
sex
a guy with a penis can still be a woman
in terms of his gender and
so so why what do you mean you're if
gender is a social construct
how can you reassign it through surgery
if gender has nothing to do with your
body
how can you reassign someone's gender
with surgery doesn't make any sense
of course nothing these p these these
maniacs say makes any sense
um so it was so this was
sex change surgery gender reassignment
surgery
um and now even more of a euphemism
because we got gender reassignment oh
we're just reassigning
as if it was a sign to begin with
because that's what the doctors do right
they just assign all they do is they
look at the baby and they come up with
with a label like slapping a sticker on
it assigning it
um but then that's even that was
too too honest and so now we're at uh
gender affirmation healthcare
we're not changing it's uh we're not
changing anything we're just
affirming by chemically castrating a 14
year old where we're affirming
something affirming him in his confusion
i suppose so yeah and it's healthcare
i mean you're using the healthcare now
you're using these drugs off label
these drugs were not made or developed
to be used by physically healthy
kids
euphemism on top of euphemism on top of
euphysm that's and that's how they get
away with this
that's how they change you know they
change public perception
and it's quite real it's quite evil
quite twisted but it's quite brilliant
on top of it
they're cut they're they're they never
constantly changing the language they
never let
they can never let it be
once people start to realize and they
get wise to the game
then the left says okay we got to change
the language again
it's it there's it's a it's a they're
innovators it's a process of innovation
now it's innovation um
for in order to deceive
it's inner innovation for the sake of
deception but it is it's innovation
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content